noch höher ist der anteil der weiblichen
abgeordneten bei der fraktion die linke
da liegt er nämlich bei 59 prozent und
eine dieser nun dieser 59 prozent ist
jetzt bei uns nämlich petra pau
bundestags-vizepräsident den nach wie
vor nämlich so lange so lange bis der
bundestag sich in gut vier wochen hier
neu konstituiert also auch das plenum
dann das erste mal komplett zusammen
kommt und so lange behalten sie auch amt
und aufgaben so ist es und diesen
besondere aufgaben in diesen tagen denen
der bundestag ist wieder mal so groß wie
nie 735 abgeordnete welche vorkehrungen
haben sie schon in der vergangenen
wahlperiode getroffen dass da eine
arbeitsfähigkeit möglich ist auch am
anfang schon ja das ist so dass in
diesen tagen jetzt die fraktionen das
erste mal zusammentreten und wir haben
tatsächlich in allen bereichen als
präsidium und mit den mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeitern der
bundestagsverwaltung vorkehrungen
getroffen dass jeder erst einmal die
möglichkeit hatte einen arbeitsplatz zu
finden und zum beispiel ich in einer
besonderen verantwortung bin ich
zuständig für die ausstattung der
abgeordneten mit informations- und
kommunikationstechnik ich könnte auch
sagen mit ihrem ersten laptop und ihre
ersten weit vorbereitet und die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter der
bundestagsverwaltung
empfangen die neuen abgeordneten erst
einmal mit einer grundausstattung
ich stelle mir das schwierig vor oder
gerade in diesem fall schwierig vor weil
ja teilweise die rede davon war wenn es
ganz dumm läuft in anführungszeichen
hätte der bundestag bis zu 1000
möglicherweise oder zumindest 900
abgeordnete haben kommen dann hat es
sich ja vergleichsweise in grenzen
gehalten was die negativszenarien angeht
wenn man das mal so nennen darf wie kann
man da oder wie läuft das dann ab dass
man sich auch auf diesen auf diesen
worst case wie man erneut so schön sagt
vorbereitet naja ich bin schon froh dass
wir bei dieser begrenzten zahl an
zuwachs geblieben sind weil irgendeiner
stelle hätten wir dann tatsächlich
schauen müssen wo wir noch räume
anmieten aber eines steht fest die
reform des wahlrechtes muss jetzt
endlich auf die tagesordnung und ich
kann in jedem fall wirklich als
vize-präsidentin nur an die fraktionen
appellieren sich das sofort auf den
tisch zu ziehen es sind vorschläge auf
dem tisch wenn jemand einen besseren hat
ist okay aber wir müssen uns wieder der
im grundgesetz vorgegebenen anzahl an
mandaten lehren das gab kann ich noch
kurz nach tragen einen gemeinsamen einen
gemeinsamen gesetzentwurf aus ihrer
fraktion der linken aber auch von grünen
und fdp gemeinsam von diesen drei
fraktionen getragen irgendwie der sich
nicht hat durchsetzen können hier gegen
die mehrheit im parlament insbesondere
gegen die unionsfraktion und da speziell
gegen die csu landesgruppe wenn man sich
das wahlergebnis anguckt weiß man
ungefähr auch warum das so gekommen ist
reichlich ganz kurze nachfrage noch
einmal zu der unterbringung und zu der
ausstattung aber so wie es vor geplant
war so sind sie jetzt auf der sicheren
seite mit den
735 na ja das wurde alles jetzt ein
bisschen brauchen ausgeschiedene
abgeordnete räumen ihre büros und das
sind nicht alle planmäßig ausgeschieden
ich kann das an meiner eigenen fraktion
besichtigen wir haben uns schmerzhaft
halbiert oder die wählerinnen und wähler
mit ihrem wahlverhalten haben dafür
gesorgt dass wir uns schmerzhaft
halbiert haben das muss jetzt geklärt
werden aber unter dem strich wird jeder
abgeordnete arbeitsfähig sein und an
sechsundzwanzigster oktober der
zwanzigste bundestag konstituiert wir
werden gleich auch noch ein bisschen
über die programmatik auf der linken
sprechen und warum es dieses ergebnis
gegeben hat ich würde aber gerne mit
ihnen zusammen zunächst noch mal gucken
was das bedeutet wenn sie haben ungefähr
30 abgeordnete glaube ich verloren in
ihrer fraktion von von 69 sind der 30
nicht mehr da was heißt das für die
arbeitsfähigkeit einer fraktion im
deutschen bundestag
wir sind im moment gerade dabei uns das
aus dem all zu treffen und zu schauen
das heißt natürlich auch dass
mitarbeiterinnen
weiter nicht in einer solchen anzahl wie
bisher zur verfügung stehen darum mache
ich mir im moment tatsächlich gedanken
weil auch diese menschen haben engagiert
uns in unserer parlamentarischen arbeit
in den abgeordnetenbüros aber auch in
der fraktion unterstützt und sie werden
zum teil ihren arbeitsplatz verlieren
gleichzeitig muss die fraktion sich
jetzt inhaltlich natürlich aufstellen
und ist auch auf qualifizierte zu arbeit
angewiesen das ist ein sehr
komplizierter prozess der auch für manch
einen sehr sehr schmerzhaft sein wird
der punkt mit den mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern ist ziemlich wichtig wie
ich finde die werden ja meistens gar
nicht wahrgenommen und nicht gesehen
sondern man sieht nur die abgeordneten
und ihre arbeit aber auch da das
natürlich schon konsequenzen die
besetzung von fachpolitischen
sprecherinnen beispielsweise geht aber
auch um die vertretung der der fraktion
in ausschüssen ja natürlich es werden
wird jeder abgeordneten jeder
abgeordnete mehrere aufgaben übernehmen
müssen und vielleicht nicht nur das
lieblingsthema vertreten also ich habe
dem bundestag aus unterschiedlichen
perspektiven erlebt als mitglied einer
fraktion noch in bonn dann mit meiner
kollegin gesine lötzsch als die herren
mich diese bilder wo sie zwei allein
richtig aufräumt nur ohne tisch ohne
fachreferenten und alles was dazu gehört
und jetzt in dieser verkleinerten
fraktion das ist eine schmerzhafte
geschichte und wir werden noch einen
moment brauchen um das auch zu
organisieren und sie sind man muss es ja
leider sagen an einer noch
dramatischeren situation ganz knapp
vorbei gerutscht denn sie haben gerade
mal zwei abgeordnete mehr als nötig um
als fraktion akzeptiert zu werden im
deutschen bundestag das heißt fünf
prozent der abgeordneten des deutschen
bundestages bilden dann eine fraktion
unabhängig vom wahlergebnis da sind sie
ja in dieser person stärke jetzt
reingerutscht ins parlament durch die so
genannte grund mandats klausel bei drei
abgeordnete
irgendwie ihren wahlkreis direkt
gewonnen haben was sind die ursachen für
dieses ergebnis frau k das ist
sicherlich komplex und wir werden
sicherlich über den wahlkampfreden
müssen aber ich glaube die ursachen
liegen tiefer und zum teil auch länger
zurück dazu gehört die frage ob man
geschlossenheit ausstrahlt aber auch und
das ist ein vorschlag von mir gar nicht
so ganz neues eine programmatische und
strategische erneuerung
können in die geschichte zurückschauen
die pds in den 1990 er jahren das war
die erste erneuerung der bruch mit dem
stalinismus die auseinandersetzung mit
der geschichte dann 2005 bis 2007 die
zweite erneuerung als gesamtdeutsche
protestpartei die sich gegen die agenda
2010 stellte und ich denke es ist
höchste zeit dass wir uns den fragen des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts noch mal
anders zu wenden den fragen des klimas
genauso wie der digitalisierung und uns
hier tatsächlich neu aufstellen aber wo
können sie da speziell akzente setzen
als linke partei denn wenn sie sagen
klima klimaschutz und digitalisierung da
gibt es in vielen anführungszeichen die
spezialisten die grünen die fdp
beispielsweise wie können sich ja als
linken verteidiger vor allem für soziale
themen gestanden hatte in den
vergangenen jahren und jahrzehnten wie
können sie da in diesen feldern dann
reduzieren unter uns dann die klimafrage
ist wahrscheinlich die größte soziale
frage überhaupt in dieser zeit weil da
geht es um das überleben der menschheit
und wir sind die letzte generation und
im übrigen aus meiner sicht auch der
letzte deutsche bundestag der hier
tatsächlich um steuern kann und es ist
klar die linke muss aller dinge die sie
bearbeitet mit der brille der sozialen
gerechtigkeit
entsprechend anschauen und das
unterscheidet und schon von fdp aber und
auch von den grünen
sie haben im wahlkampf angesprochen dass
der aus ihrer sicht nicht optimal
gelaufen ist was hätte besser sein
müssen auch da sind wir noch am anfang
der analyse aber ich denke
wahlkampfzeiten sind ernste zeiten und
da muss man mit einer stimme sprechen
und in knappen ordentlich erfassbaren
bildern erklären was sind unsere mut
machenden alternativen das ist uns
offensichtlich nicht überall gelungen
und sie sagen ernten sind erntezeiten
aber er hätte man möglicherweise auch
vorher an dass pflanzen müssen oder na
ja da gab es da hatten die
entschuldigung ins gewissen leerlauf
auch so eine übergangsphase was im
parteivorsitz an ging ja gut keiner
konnte ahnen dass corona uns auch noch
erhält wir hätten einige frühe unsere
neue parteiführung wählen wollen konnten
dies nicht unter den crooner bedingungen
das ist kein vorwurf an die beiden neuen
parteivorsitzenden die in dieser kurzen
zeit versucht haben die parteien nicht
nur durch den wahlkampf zu führen
sondern auch liegengebliebenes
aufzuarbeiten
nun werden wir es grundlegend gemeinsam
anpacken wir haben das thematische
zumindest schon mal angerissen wo sie
ihrer meinung nach sicher die linke
zukünftig je deutlicher positionieren
muss oder anders und dann aber auch neue
akzente anbieten musste den wählerinnen
und wählern es gab ja in den vergangenen
monaten auch immer die diskussion auf
welche wählerinnen und wähler schichten
sich denn überhaupt auch die linke
konzentrieren wir uns an die diskussion
zwischen sarah wagenknecht nun
beispielsweise katja kipping die das
sogenannte urbane milieu das akademische
großstadt million enger in den blick
nehmen wollte wohin sahra wagenknecht er
auf gefühlte und tatsächlich
benachteiligt gucken wollte und die
mitnehmen ist etwas das ich halte das
für falsch da beides oder das in dieser
weise gegenüber zu stellen wir stehen
hier in berlin mein wahlkreis ist ein
land bezirks wahlkreis außerhalb des s
bahn ringes gleichzeitig haben wir am
wochenende hier landtagswahlen in berlin
gehabt und die linke hat vergleichsweise
gut abgeschnitten also zumindest wenn
ich jetzt bundestags und
das nebeneinander legen und das kann nur
gelingen wenn wir tatsächlich sowohl das
urbane städtischen milieu ansprechen auf
ihre spezifischen interessen mit
eingehen aber auch diejenigen die
beispielsweise in marzahn hellersdorf in
armut leben und ich habe viele kinder
beispielsweise die noch nichts anderes
kennen als hartz iv-bezug abschließend
noch eine persönliche frage sie waren
viele jahre direkt gewählte abgeordnete
haben ihren wahlkreis immer gewonnen
jetzt kommen sie als über die liste in
den bundestag ist macht das einen
unterschied in der gefühlten unterschied
also der schmerz war schon ziemlich
gross am sonntagabend dass ich nicht
direkt in den bundestag gewählt wurde
aber mein versprechen ist ich nehme mein
mann dort hier an und werde genauso für
die bürgerinnen und bürger da sein wie
vor denke auch die arbeit ist ja die
selbe die auch in zukunft und sie wird
noch herausforderung als die unter den
bedingungen die sie jetzt haben als
deutlich kleinere fraktionen als in den
vorherigen jahren petra pau ist nach wie
vor bundestags-vizepräsidentin
mindestens noch bis ungefähr ende
oktober vielen dank dass sie heute bei
uns gewesen sind danke